yeah baby you got this so good goart
thank you guys for coming by the way I
know it means a lot to him that you're
here Amy of course what the is her
deal man shut up she right next to us
what is her problem she's fine man she's
she's honestly really nice it's just I
don't know why Martin is so afraid he's
petrified right now looks like he's
being held at gunpoint I know and what
the is going on with that suit I
don't know man it's huge dude he looks
like the son he looks like a
pimp in a high school play I baptize
thee in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy
Ghost you are now
baptized that was so
good my own heart
what still be my
viision oh
ruler of
you get any pigs in a blanket no more of
a fan of the blanket
myself are you kidding me man what you
just suck the bread off that I should
I'm more of a fan of the blanket I heard
what you said man was disgusting the
words of John Lennon All You Need Is
Love two baddies in hell for doing
drugs
I